okay first things first i have not seen
doctor strange two so if any of this is
in the movie that i apologize ahead of
time i just simply didn't know
i want to say that because we're about
two weeks out and early press screenings
are going on right now because they're
doing the press junket for it or the
press tour as some people call it so
there's leaks and rumors and things like
that coming out now more so than before
and if you guys are interested we can
cover that i know a lot of you guys try
to avoid spoilers early on but i want to
talk about this idea of galactus right
so here's the thing there's a few things
that we're going to borrow from and
we're going to kick this off by kind of
focusing on wanda for a second because
potentially she could kind of be the
connection here not directly but
indirectly in terms of what she
represents so based on the trailers that
we've seen in doctor strange too
specifically the scene where like you
have one wanda who's on her knees that
looks like this in like the scarlet
witch attire and you have another wanda
who is it looks like the wanda from the
main marvel cinematic universe that it
looks like every universe has its own
version of wanda now i'm taking that at
face value there are leaks and rumors
but we don't know anything until the
movie actually comes out but let's say
for example that that's the case right
that version of wanda has like her kids
and all that kind of stuff and maybe the
events of west view happen maybe they
didn't right that's just one of those
things that goes on that what happens
with each wanda in each universe is just
contextual who knows how things play out
maybe she actually did have kids maybe
some weird thing happened where vision
was turned into a human and they banged
and she popped out some kids and here we
are right we have no idea how that stuff
plays out but let's assume for example
just on a baseline here that wanda is a
universal constant let's also assume the
role of like the sorcerer supreme is a
universal constant now let's kind of
expand that out a little bit in the
marvel cinematic universe one of the
things we know from the eternals films
and really some of the information that
came about the celestials before the
eternals film is that the celestials
predate the universe the only way to
predate the universe is to either
survive from a previous universe or to
come into this universe from the
multiverse from like a different reality
now we don't really know right the only
thing we know about the celestials in
terms of like a concrete definition is
according to irish and the judge they're
responsible for the creation of
everything within the universe itself
now whether that's true or not we don't
know i mean i will say that like irishm
seemed a little suspicious right i mean
he seems like the kind of guy that would
lie
[Laughter]
i don't know that's necessarily true but
let's assume that's true let's assume
that the celestials predate the universe
having come from a previous iteration of
the universe or something along those
lines now on the surface we could say
okay well this is the marvel comics
origin of galactus that galactus was a
space explorer named galin trying to
understand why his universe was coming
to an end he ultimately never figured it
out but the sentence of that universe
i.e eternity more or less merged itself
with galin and then he was reborn into
the new universe as galactus a being
that just travels around the cosmos and
absorbs the life-sustaining energy of
different planets in order to keep
himself alive why because he just does
that's just how it is so the thing about
this is while that would be the simple
explanation to go with there is a
prevailing theory that's been going on
around out there that galactus is
actually a rogue celestial that
somewhere along the line he ended up
going awry now let's assume for example
that in doctor strange 2 that the
illuminati could make a reference to
this right and they could say well you
know some kind of offhanded remark
there's a lot you don't know stephen is
strange like you like you don't even
know that you have a galactus in your
universe right that sounds like
something that would happen that like mr
fantastic would say right that like john
krasinski's reed richards assuming he's
actually playing that character it
sounds like an offhanded remark that he
would make because in marvel comics reed
richards and the fantastic four go hand
in hand with galactus and in fact you
see them with galactus more often than
you see anybody else dealing with
galactus like it really is either just a
silver surfer or the fantastic four
or like thanos beating the crap out of
him but whatever the case is the
fantastic four and galactus go hand in
hand now if that's the case if he says
something like that right like you don't
even know you have a galactus in your
own universe that establishes galactus
as a multiversal constant every universe
has its own version of galactus not an
overly important point but to the theory
about the idea of of galactus basically
being a rogue celestial there's room for
this and it actually comes from
something that marvel comics recently
made so in marvel they released a story
not too long ago called dark ages and it
was it was a cool story for what it was
the ending happened like that it just
happened way too fast right they wrapped
it up super super quick it was rushed
but what they introduced in this story
was something called the unmaker now
that was not galactus and it was not any
version of galactus instead what had
happened for reasons that don't make
sense to anybody that the unmaker was
basically a giant humanoid machine that
was created for the purpose of
essentially consuming black holes to
stop the destruction of the universe
that it was in because if black holes
were allowed to just sort of continue on
unchecked they would ultimately consume
everything now whether or not that's
true i don't really know it's comic
books who cares whether or not it works
the important thing here is that
ultimately the unmaker was basically
defeated right he was essentially
destroyed with a constant emp that shut
down all power to the earth hence the
reason why it was called marvel dark
ages now let's take that concept not the
unmaker but let's take that concept and
expand it out because what ended up
happening with the unmaker is it became
corrupted by all the power it was
consuming and just started consuming
galaxies it was ultimately locked away
in the center of the earth by the living
tribunal so if we talk about that
concept of corruption there is a big
like wait a minute hold on like a huge
problem with this theory but i do want
to throw this out there to see what you
guys think so let's say the galactus is
a rogue celestial let's say that he is
he is floating out there somewhere say
that every universe has its own version
of galactus one of which may look more
like the one that we're familiar with
from marvel comics and one of which may
look more like a celestial from the
marvel cinematic universe but let's say
that in the mcu the galactus was quite
literally a a celestial right instead of
it being like irishman the judge it was
galactus the devourer and literally what
he would do is he would travel around
the cosmos and basically whenever the
celestials showed up on a world and they
would judge it that if they judged
against it galactus would be sent there
galactus would basically cleanse the
earth by effectively consuming it by
consuming all life-sustaining energy so
nothing could grow there and then in
turn the celestials would restart the
process of creating life on that world
like literally instead of it just being
uh issan the searcher who would use the
power stone and cleanse the whole planet
then instead galactus would do it but by
whatever manner and whatever means
galactus ended up becoming corrupted now
it could be with like all the
life-sustaining energy that he was
consuming literally he just became a guy
who hungers all the time so instead of
it him being like he's powered by the
sentience of a universe and so now he
has to consume life-sustaining energies
in order to keep himself alive that what
happened is over the course of however
many billions of years he was just
consuming the life energies of world
after world after world and it got to
the point where it's quite literally out
of control right where he's just eating
all the time he just always has this
hunger so much so that it actually
started to move into the direction of
him consuming worlds that he wasn't
supposed to be consuming because he just
had to satiate his hunger this led to a
war or battle between galactus and the
celestials and that ultimately the
celestials won galactus was defeated
likely locked away somewhere if they
ever wanted you know just to establish
the fact that like he could return as
opposed to them just killing him because
i have a hard time believing that
they're going to be like hey guys
galactus is in the mcu or at least he
was until the celestials killed him 10
billion years ago like that would be
really disappointing right like people
want to see galactus now so basically
saying like he was defeated maybe put in
some kind of state of hibernation or
something like that right but basically
locked away and that in turn the
celestials had to find some method of
being able to cleanse a planet and
that's when they basically started using
the infinity stones that he saw on the
searcher would use the power stone and
he would be the one to basically
annihilate all life on a planet why
because they saw what happened when a
celestial started consuming the life
energies of a world that led to galactus
and so instead of them consuming worlds
they would just use the power stone to
wipe out life on those worlds and that
would basically be yet right that would
just be the end of it now if if marvel
really wants to build on this they can
say that when thanos blinked out half
the life in the universe that galactus
was part of that but when galactus was
snapped back when half the life of the
universe was returned by the incredible
hulk galactus woke up right he literally
just snapped right up right just woke up
out of nowhere like we saw that in the
in one division there were people who
were like in surgery or there were
people who were unconscious and when
they were snapped back they snapped back
in a woken up state and so it's just
like okay like literally they woke up
when they emerged if that's the case it
makes sense that that would happen with
galactus i think it's a good way to
bring him into the mcu it's a good way
to bring him in there to say like he's
always been there that way you can
explain his hunger instead of just being
like well he's from a previous universe
where he merged with that universe's
sentience and he's here now and he's
just consuming things and not really
having to worry about like why haven't
we ever seen him before right how come
the celestials never mentioned him
because literally the celestials
defeated him and so just kind of like
why would they i mean
like why would they think about him
right i mean it's not as though like you
shred a document and then you spend your
days wondering and talking about it no
like once you're done with that thing
you throw it away and you never think
about it again and that's exactly what
happened with galactus like the
celestial's defeated him and then
basically he's been locked away ever
since but now he's back and so i'm
curious to see what you guys think
because i think that doctor strange 2 is
the perfect way to introduce that doctor
strange 2 is the perfect way to bring
that in that what it does is it
basically gives us this explanation that
galactus is intertwined directly with
the celestials that he's a part of the
celestials that there's a galactus in
every single universe which falls into
his comic book counterpart and then in
turn is this explanation of like how
powerful he is or where he got his
hunger from why he has to consume things
different stuff along those lines now
how you tie into the idea of heralds i
don't really know and that's one of the
big caveats i mean it's a small one
right it's not the most important thing
going on right now but like how do you
tie into heralds and if galactus were
somehow able to make his way back what
would stop the celestials from just
defeating him again and then locking him
away right what would make things
different now than before perhaps
because the the universe is more
populated now which means that there's
more life energies in the worlds that he
consumes so basically he gets a power
boost and so now the celestials can't
necessarily defeat him in the comics the
reason why nobody ever kills galactus so
they're not supposed to uh the reason
why they're supposed to just let
galactus do their thing is because he's
part of the cosmic order it's his role
in the universe in the same way that the
role of a black hole is to consume
everything that comes across its path
that the purpose of galactus is to
travel around and basically uh consume
life-sustaining worlds now marvel tried
to expand on that uh in the early 2000s
with the introduction of abraxas
basically saying that like galactus was
the gatekeeper and so if galactus died
abraxas would emerge and abraxas
represented like the multiversal the
destruction of the multiverse right he
just he just represented pure
unadulterated destruction it was okay
and like ultimately he was defeated but
marvel in more recent years is just kind
of like it's what galactus does it's
just his thing and as comic book fans
who love galactus we're just kind of
like yep
that's what he does is there any real
rhyme or reason to the fact that he does
that not really but we don't care
because galactus is cool
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you think down in the comments
section about this theory if whether or
not doctor strange would like
potentially bring in this idea there are
theories also circulating around out
there that the creation or at least the
the introduction of galactus actually
comes by way of the meddling of kang the
conqueror which i think is really really
cool like galactus is a result of kang i
think that's people trying to justify
galactus existence in the same way that
people were like thanos made galactus
when he created the infinity stones or
when he used the infinity stones it's
like a backup plan right that like he
would blink out half the life in the
universe and then galactus would just
travel around the universe and consume
life-sustaining worlds thereby keeping
the population in check uh that i
thought was a great theory at the time
whether or not it will ring true we have
no idea but nonetheless let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section and i will catch you all later
peace